what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing our Marvel cosmic
stuff really kind of like following the
Thanos chronology of things at this
point we pick up with Thanos the second
death and it's kind of interesting
because remember this is all part of
that whole jim Starlin run this is one
of the reasons why jim Starlin was so
important as a writer is because he kind
of flushed out and expanded the Marvel
cosmology that really led to the works
of guys like Dan Abnett people along
those lines but the idea here was that
following the original Cosmic Cube saga
the Cosmic Cube story whatever you want
to call it the whole idea was that
Thanos had effectively been defeated and
where the Cosmic Cube had been destroyed
by Captain Marvel what ended up
happening
his Marvel had effectively used the
energies to kind of set things back to
the way they were before and what he did
is it allowed Jack Kirby to sort of
refresh things to a degree in the sense
that Thanos just kind of ended up in the
center of the universe and it allowed
him to kind of go among his various
schemes and plans of different things
along those lines now following that and
what we covered in our Adam warlock
explained video was that Stahl and then
went into something that focus
exclusively on Adam warlock that was
called the Magus trilogy and what ended
up happening with the Magus trilogy is
it basically grabbed the character of
Adam warlock who had already been like a
Stanley Jack Kirby Roy Thomas kind of
character and was really more of like a
baseline messianic superhero as opposed
to like a cosmic hero warlock had been
elevated to the cosmic level by jim
Starlin and the Magus saga basically
detailed this idea that somewhere along
the line in the distant future Adam
warlock would be corrupted by the soul
Jim just because of the fact that of all
the infinity gems that are out there the
soul stone kind of has a mind of its own
and the subsidence for the souls of
people who wield it and if they don't
protect themselves adequately it'll take
their souls and so that was kind of be
locked inside the soul stone forever now
the result was that when Thanos had
returned what he'd realize or at least
what he'd done is he'd effectively read
this old scroll and that's one of the
things that are that that's really kind
of hinted out here in this sense that
Adam warlock really just kind of making
his way throughout the cosmos and so on
and so forth ultimately comes across
Gamora now part of The Magus saga was
introducing Gamora as basically a girl
who is part of a group called the Zin
well Barris there were really just kinda
like a pacifist race and their race had
been totally obliterated save for Gamora
who was one of the only survivors and
then also basically taken her and then
made her into a personal assassin with
cybernetic augmentation honing combat
skills different things like that and
made her the most formidable assassin in
the entirety of the universe and so what
Adam warlock shows up and
basically gamora's effectively been
taken out the question is who did it why
and what's the next step and so what
this does is this transitions over to
the Avengers themselves and it's kind of
interesting because there are a few
characters here that I do want to talk
about 4-cycle really only one to be
honest there is a character named moon
dragon and we did talk about the origin
of moon dragon how her character evolved
how she progressed but she's basically a
girl named Heather Douglas she's the
daughter of Drax the destroyer and again
one of the things that we hit on was
that when Thanos had initially showed up
on earth it was part of like a scouting
mission that he had been spotted by the
family of arthur douglas arthur douglas
his wife and his daughter
and so that ohs basically destroyed the
vehicle of arthur douglas killed Arthur
killed his wife and was believed to have
killed Heather
but Heather survived she was taken by
the father of Thanos and had her
telepathic powers developed and so as a
result Heather Douglas you know moon
dragon without any real like external
augmentation which is to say like you
know like with when Jean Grey and had
it's the Phoenix force or something
along those lines Heather Douglas is one
of the top telepaths in the entirety of
the Marvel Universe but much like you
know Drax a destroyer
she harbors a desire to see the
destruction of Thanos so it's one of
those interesting things that goes on
the problem with this is that while
they're discussing events that have
unfolded moondragon really kind of shows
up and says we have a major problem when
the question is why what she says as
someone's traveling around the cosmos
blinking out stars they're basically
destroying stars and so because of the
fact that moon dragons telepathy is so
incredibly powerful it's almost like
that scene from Star Wars you know we're
like all the Rams destroyed and then
obi-wan Kenobi feels it through the
force that's how it is with a moon
dragon the entire population of various
planets are totally obliterated and moon
dragon effectively kind of feels that
through her telepathy and it feels all
those lives being snuffed out all the
fear they feel in the blink of an eye
and suddenly you know a fraction of a
second they're all basically gone now at
this point one of the things I also want
to talk about is the idea of beasts
being rolled over into the Avengers so
back during the events of Avengers
number 137 hey McCoy was kind of
inducted into the Avengers proper just
not really and dr. proper he was kind of
inducted as like a probationary member
wasn't until 151 or 157 that he was
actually inducted into the team properly
but the whole idea was that back in the
nineteen really the 1970s you know and I
- yeah I guess in the 1970s the whole
shake-up at Marvel when it came to the
x-men was trying to find the way to like
reinvigorate interest in the team per se
and when beast initially gained his you
know is his blue fur that was an event
or an attempt to kind of try to shake
him up a little bit but over the course
of publications like Amazing Adventures
and Marvel adventures
it was an attempt to kind of like rework
him but that's the reason why he's here
he's just kind of a probationary member
one of the big controversial aspects of
jim Starlin writing beast is that on the
whole beast is kind of like a high
intellect kindly being mean that he is
exceedingly smart and he's also really
nice one of the big problems people had
is that jim Starlin wrote beast is kind
of a dick making fun of people's
ideologies and like telepathy isn't
really that relevant and things like
that which is kind of weird especially
considering he spent so much time
alongside jean grey so that was one of
the things that a lot of people didn't
really care for when it came to his
whole thing with him being so cynical
but what is up happening is that in the
middle of all this the group is
basically met by the arrival of Adam
warlock now keep in mind for most of
these guys this is the first time
they've met him or it's really the
second time they met him like in the
case of Thor Thor has not seen Adam
warlock since the first time they fought
when Adam warlock was just him again
because of that for a lot of these guys
they don't necessarily trust warlock
because they don't know him or the last
time they met they were in conflict and
so because of this with moon dragon
being a probationary member of the
Avengers and really kind of like being
trusted by the team ultimately she just
kind of spills the beans and says hey
look this guy's a good guy he's not here
to work against us he's here to work for
us for the most part warlock basically
says look I'm aware of everything you
guys have done in your first battle with
Thanos all those different things when
Thanos was rendered back to being
immortal when he was taken by a ship so
on and so forth but what ended up
happening is that when Thanos was
defeated after the events of the Cosmic
Cube saga he was quote-unquote abandoned
my mistress death and this is when it
starts to bring into the whole idea of
Thanos and mistress death in this kind
of cat-and-mouse game in a sense that
Thanos chases mistress death and she
runs away but the whole idea is that
when Thanos had basically been defeated
what he had done is he had looked to
find a way to regain the affections of
mistress death and in doing so had
actually searched a series of dead
worlds ultimately coming across a scroll
that revealed the existence of the
Infinity stones now this is where we
really see jim Starlin grab the stones I
kind of bring them together as like very
powerful artifacts but this is the first
time that us gains the Infinity stones
this is not Thanos quest Thanos quest
basically Ari details the whole idea of
the Infinity stones but Thanos learns
more about what they're capable of
instead of what he learns here
he really learns from this this scroll
is that these stones are wildly powerful
that if a person uses them they'll have
an extreme amount of power he doesn't
know about the Infinity Gauntlet yet
again all that comes during Thanos quest
and so because of this wedding is of
doing is kind of like traversing the
entirety of the universe and locating
each one of these artifacts each one of
these stones one of the first ones that
he finds belongs to the stranger that
essentially breaks in he steals it and
then he starts hopping across the cosmos
grabbing all these different Infinity
stones from all these different
locations now the only exception to this
is the soul stone of Adam warlock and
the reason why is because with the soul
stone again being hungry and basically
capturing the souls of individuals who
don't necessarily guard it properly
Thanos his biggest concern was that he
would basically lose his soul to the
soul stone and so that's where the whole
Magus auga came into play the idea was
if Thanos needed the power of the soul
stone but didn't want to possess it
you know outright and so what he did is
when he realized that Adam warlock was
destined to become the Magus he started
putting in all these different schemes
in these different plans that would
basically ensure that future never
really came to fruition instead that
future would just be an alternate
reality or something like that and one
of the schemes involved like getting
gomorrah turning her into an assassin
another involved a lying himself with
adam warlock to defeat the Magus and so
because these things Thanos what he was
doing really all the while that he was
working alongside Adam warlock during
the Magus augur was actually siphoning
off the energy of the soul stone without
Adam warlock realizing it and so what
had happened is Gamora had come across
the plans of Thanos where he intended to
take all the energies of these Infinity
stones and combine them into a singular
large synthetic Jim and then used that
to start blinking out stars and that's
when Thanos turned on her and that's
where Adam warlock picked up at the
beginning of the story when gomorrah had
been defeated and so again because of
the fact that pip the troll was kind of
just a guy who was there and worked
alongside Adam warlock for a little
while his allegiances aren't necessarily
guaranteed for pit patrol he was there
during the Magus saga and so he kind of
considered himself to be a friend of
Thanos and Adam warlock but the whole
idea here is that because pip the troll
is more allied with Adam than he is with
Thanos when he comes along and atheros
his ship's kind of swords poking around
and begins to realize what's happening
Thanos effectively turns on him and says
well we're effectively going to just
have to do something to get rid of you
or to remove you from this whole
scenario and so what this does is this
picks up with the various superheroes
trying
figure out what it is that's going on
with regards to the forces of Thanos
where it is that he's at and what he's
trying to do it so ultimately what is up
happening is statuses next move brings
him to the saul system basically brings
him to earth where he intends to blink
out Earth's star but again it is kind of
interesting because what is up happening
here is in the middle of this whole
conflict with this army of Thanos that
he's been using to basically keep
himself protected you end up having like
Marvel of the Kree you end up having
Iron Man and you end up having Thor
basically like abandon the major
conflict and then basically take off to
the ship of Thanos the problem with this
is that when Adam warlock when he shows
up he ends up finding pip the troll it's
just kind of in a catatonic state and so
this begins for those of you guys who
read like or who saw my videos on Thanos
quest which those will go back up when
we had the opening of the story really I
guess maybe was Infinity Gauntlet oh he
had the opening of the story where pip
the troll and Gamora and Adam warlock
were inside the soul stone this is why
that happens because in this particular
moment what ends up taking place here is
Adam warlock because of the fact of the
mind of Pip the troll is destroyed he
basically takes his soul his essence and
absorbs it into the soul stone and so
this kind of like leaves it there as a
place where pivot role can kind of
experience eternity living in an idea
like paradise as opposed to just kind of
being locked away in stuck inside of his
own mind and so what this does is this
transitions to really kind of like a
massive battle between like Thor out of
warlock Marvel of the Kree and iron man
who show up on the actual ship of Thanos
and begin the process of just destroying
the giant synthetic infinity gym now the
funny thing about that is that in the
midst of this whole thing there's a
couple things to keep in mind if you
were a reader of Marvel Comics vector in
the 1970s when this story came out this
was a huge deal and the reason why is
because of the fact that you had marvel
of the creep and then you had Adam
warlock and there were characters who in
a lot of ways had been like fleshed out
and kind of built by jim Starlin despite
the fact that he didn't necessarily
create them and so because of the fact
it would be like if Captain America and
Iron Man met for the first time it was a
pretty big deal the problem with this is
that in the middle of this fight uh you
end up having Adam warlock really whose
powers just kind of drained by Thanos
and ultimately he's basically just
destroyed and so it leaves like Thor and
it leaves a handful of others to try to
pick up the slack and Iron Man of course
destroys a synthetic Jim and so as a
result of this Thanos just kind of bails
out takes off and then he's more or less
like you know you guys are going to meet
your final fate you guys are gonna be
destroyed you know and that's really
gonna be about it and so what is up
happening
is Adam warlocks essence really kind of
like leaves the physical plane and he
basically transitions to the soul stone
and this is when Adam warlock really
begins to learn more about the soul
stone than he did before where Adam
warlock was aware of the fact that the
soul stone would basically lock away the
souls of people who didn't guard it
adequately at the end of the day it was
relatively interesting because having
that information and experiencing that
information are usually two distinctly
different things and when he enters into
the soul stone and he meets not only
former enemies who had their souls
captured as well as gomorrah and pit
patrol he actually doesn't want to leave
and so what this does is it actually
transitions to a line of comics called
Marvel two-in-one now Marvel has read
launched this as part of Marvel legacy
but it's basically just kind of an
ongoing series with Johnny Storm and the
thing which is kind of the basis for it
but originally Marvel two-in-one was
basically just a series where you would
have a whole bunch of stories with the
thing Ben Grimm and he would just team
up with other people now the stories
were contextual largely because of the
fact that Marvel 2 and one was really
kind of had his popularity bolstered by
Ben Grimm the idea was to basically say
wool if you want to write a story that
fits into a larger story that you're
already telling you can do it in Marvel
two-in-one and then both of the
popularity of that story or if we're
just looking to kind of fill a
publication hole we can just tell any
regular story it doesn't matter it was
just a team-up book but the fact remains
here that what this does is it basically
sees a team-up between Ben Grimm and
spider-man and this is smart because
remember spider-man has always been
Marvel's highest selling publications
when it comes to individual solo
superhero titles and throwing him into
this book bolstered the readership
because it gave fans a reason who
wouldn't normally read something like
this to read it because it involves
spider-man and so as a result what is up
happening is you end up having basically
moondragon user telepathy to essentially
blast the mind of Peter Parker with
information on everything that's
happened basically an attempt to say hey
look we need help we can't do this on
our own now something else that I also
want to talk about here is the
introduction of Master Order and Lord
Kaos order and chaos are designed to
represent exactly what they sound like
order and chaos neither one of them can
be an absolute control if chaos was an
absolute control the universe would just
be kind of in shambles it would be in
pieces it'd be weird if order was the
one running the show everything would be
exceedingly regimented and structured
and so these two represent diametrically
opposed ngey cotta means in the sense
that you have to have order combined
with chaos and so this introduction of
these two cosmic beings really comes by
way of well who knows how this will play
yeah like if they walk the standard
ordered superhero archetype they'll win
but if someone throws a wrench in the
works they won't win and so that's kind
of what these two characters represented
so you end up having Peter Parker who
travels to go meet Ben Grimm and it
makes sense because for the most part
the Fantastic Four are like the premier
group when it comes to chartering a
space waste when it comes to like going
out into space and dealing with various
conflicts and so because of that what
we're not necessarily told why the
Fantas look for on here which is to say
why like Reed Richards Susan storm and
Johnny Storm on here Ben Grimm basically
just like takes a ship him a Peter
Parker board it going to find nanos and
ultimately like they jump into fray with
all the various forces that Thanos has
at his disposal and so on and so forth
that part's pretty straightforward now
this was one of those unplanned things
when it comes to Thanos but keep in mind
while the modern-day stories you'll
really kind of illustrate the idea that
Thanos is one of the smartest beings out
there when it comes to like military
strategy and overall knowledge of
different things these early stories
really emphasize the idea that Thanos
was just like a warlord and so as time
progresses going into the future of
these stories the various experiences he
has like these where he loses during the
Cosmic Cube saga where he experiences
the afterlife mistress death things like
that that will all go towards bolstering
up his abilities as a really one of the
most powerful entities out there and so
what isn't happening here is that Adam
warlock you know as he's in this soul
stone you know again because of the fact
he doesn't necessarily want to leave he
kind of experiences this tugging of
sorts this pulling of sorts in the sense
that there are well really it just kind
of seems like the stones sort of trying
to spit him back out that he's sort of
destined to defeat Thanos quote-unquote
it's kind of ambiguous but it is one of
those interesting scenarios because what
ends up taking place if Stannis
basically kind of reveals to spider-man
and Ben Grimm what we already know that
he's basically been traveling around
with the various stones that of course
he captured the soul stone of Adam
warlock he's kind of holding it in
stasis in a giant crystal ball of sorts
but his idea is to basically start
blinking out stars and he's looking to
blink out the star of Earth just because
of the fact that earth really harbors
most of the threats really most of the
annoyances as far as Thanos is concerned
that were Ben Grimm and spider-man do
the best they can to try to take out
Thanos
ultimately they're successful to a
degree but spider-man just kind of like
bails out and it's kind of funny the way
it's done because he's just like okay
looks like this guy's really powerful
and this guy could easily quash me so
I'm out peace and just bails like he
literally just takes off but the funny
thing about this is partway through he
begins to realize that if
someone doesn't stop Thanos then either
spider-man's going to die at the hands
of Thanos here or spider-man's gonna die
when the Earth's sons obliterated and so
either way it seems like there's no real
way for him to escape this fate unless
he's able to you know basically help
defeat Thanos and that's exactly what he
does what he ends up doing is kind of
sneaking back aboard and then
effectively destroy the prison apartment
being used to kind of keep all the
Avengers and stasis which of course
leads to them being freed and then all
of them finding Thanos now in the middle
of all this one is up taking place is
that the fight is actually pretty
hardcore but this is something that I
want you guys to notice the way this is
done is not really the way we would
expect you to see back the way that US
was done back in the back in this era
back in this this line of storytelling
he was more of a grounded character he
was a person who could be defeated
nowadays we would never expect this
Thanos is a is a being who's so
incredibly powerful right now in the
modern day
Thanos would wreck them all
single-handedly without any real effort
whatsoever it would be no contest but
that's the evolution of fast
that's the various abilities he's gained
over the years combined with his
experience in wisdom in fighting these
guys before but what is up happening
here is of course because of the fact
that Adam warlock is feeling this kind
of continual tug from the soul stone
when Peter Parker it is kind of like
knocks it over knocks over this this
encasing and basically destroys the
housing of the soul stone Adam warlock
emerges and that essentially just seizes
Thanos and turns into stone now again
this is classic Marvel we're not given
like a line-by-line indication of
exactly what was done we're just told
he's turning to solid granite done and
that's that's really yet it's pretty
straightforward and it's pretty simple
but all this was designed to do is
basically show that Thanos has
effectively defeated the Thanos has
essentially gone and so because of this
Adam warlock just kind of retreats back
into the soul stone again and he's just
sort of left there you know he alongside
Gamora and pip the troll just sort of
reside inside the soul stone and at some
point or another they may or may not
come back but what this was designed to
do is basically put Adam warlock Gamora
in pit the troll on the back burner it
was a way for for really for jim Starlin
to kind of flush out other things
outside of this particular line of
comics so that he could basically bring
back Adam warlock a more and pit the
troll during the events of Infinity
Gauntlet so again just kind of sitting
them in a sword shed and bring him back
out when he wants them again but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb cork if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop on
and I will catch you all later peace
[Music]